bom eu irei falar sobre a segregação do
século 21 o que é segregação do século
quando nós falamos em segregação nós
pensamos nisso na segregação que ocorreu
nos estados unidos na década de 50 60 e
70 foi seu apogeu é todo mundo estudou
na escola sobre isso mas essa segregação
foi algo que ocorreu lá e no nós temos
repúdio sobre isso nós olhamos essa
imagem e ficamos pensando meu deus como
isso aconteceu e e pensamos já passou
ficou no passado mas infelizmente isso
ainda ocorre de forma um perceptível
aqui o mapa da nossa porto alegre antiga
porto alegre olha como era antigamente
esses bairros que nós temos com ele que
nós conhecemos como bonfim mãos errar e
genô polis rio branco eles não eram os
bairros como a gente conhece agora eles
eram baixos de pessoas pobres pessoas
negras era conhecido como colônia
africana o bairro bomfim eo parque
redenção só tem esse nome porque as
famílias que moravam lá colocar este
nome e depois o poder público motor
parque farroupilha mas infelizmente
nunca pegou eles não tiveram sorte nisso
e ficou sempre nós chamamos de redenção
quando que começou tudo isso essa
questão de segregar colocar as famílias
pobres na margem da da cidade em 1945
com a nova a legislação de urbanização
da cidade e depois na década de 60 com
um programa remover para promover
quiseram pegar as famílias pobres da
cidade nessa parte central e colocaram
em bairros como vila jardim passo
d'areia área de floresta ea líbia onde
era localizado aqui onde o bairro bonfim
as pessoas que moravam ali quis
antigamente era chamado ilhota foram
para a restinga por isso que o bairro
restinga se concentram muitas pessoas
pobres e negras porque todos foram
colocados para lá há uma questão também
é interessante é que eles não querem que
tenha muita locomoção entre os dois
povos porque queria duas cidades na
cidade central e uma cidade
marginalizada impulso só tinha dois
ônibus que faziam o transbordo diário
entre a restinga e o centro da cidade
nós não temos acesso mesmo as pessoas
ficar assim
a centralizado e as pessoas
marginalizadas bom isso chama
gentrificação el é um termo inglês nem
gente fiquei chan não tencionam me
engano não tem no dicionário em
português ainda mas o que a gente ficar
são é quando nós removemos pessoas
geralmente uma renda de um lugar e
colocamos em outro para promover aqueles
bairros por exemplo eu fazer comércio
empresa 70 é isso aconteceu em nova
iorque porto alegre rio de janeiro são
paulo são francisco na califórnia e em
algumas cidades em portugal também
bom vamos no ponto que eu queria trazer
falar sobre segregação que acontece
quando nos separamos os povos por cor
anpur a renda isso gera uma segregação e
o que acontece quando marginalizando os
habitantes de uma cidade que iríamos
antes inóspitos porque evidentemente o
poder público esquece deixa no
ostracismo aquelas pessoas que ele
colocou na margem e isso volta contra a
produção porque começa a esqueceram da
educação de qualidade saneamento básico
a violência volta das cidades entram
então ele diz paliativas isso tentar
botar o problema por um lado nós devemos
resolver o que isso acontece também
provoca se uma limitação de
relacionamentos as pessoas não se
conhecem porque quem mora no central e
mora na volta não tem uma interatividade
até porque não frequenta os mesmos
ambientes então gera polarização pessoas
preconceituosas sem empatia intolerantes
vida paralela vida paralela eu falo que
quando começa a viver uma vida paralela
devido essa marginalização e essa
insegurança
nós cada vez mais precisamente no brasil
precisamos isolar
precisamos viver em ambientes mais
seguros então nós geralmente preocupamos
shoppings andamos apenas de carros
compra no caso em condomínios que
vivemos em clubes o que ocorre quando o
fato acontece isso tudo começa a
conviver apenas com as pessoas do mesmo
ambiente e começa a se tornar uma pessoa
polarizada
pode-se dizer preconceituosa porque não
tem a empatia pelo outro não conhece o
outro achei estranho se torna pessoas e
isso é um é um erro digamos assim porque
países desenvolvidos como canadá e
europa
nós eles priorizam a
convivência em harmonia com a população
e não se enclausurar em ambientes
fechados tentando criar uma outra
realidade eles tanto como diria que ela
é bobeira e não viver a realidade temos
que enfrentar os problemas
o que podemos fazer as soluções básicas
evidentemente que esse problema
extremamente complexo precisamos de
políticas públicas para combater o
problema
mas como nós jovens podemos fazer o que
nós poderíamos fazer escola aí como a
comunidade escolar e as escolas deveriam
incentivar o debate teve um debate essa
semana aqui no colégio israelita e foi
ótimo eu acho porque temos que debater
isso mesmo é uma forma de a uma das
ferramentas que nós vamos combater a
intolerância de todo tipo de
intolerância religiosa e política e tem
outra coisa escolas privadas estaduais e
municipais criarem uma rede de
comunicação assim todos os alunos
consigam se comunicar e trazer mais
empatia trocar idéias aprender com o
outro a esac é bem interessante é que eu
nunca havia falado também as pessoas os
jovens fazem parte da mesma as tribos o
padrão de consumo aspirado entre os
jovens é o mesmo os jovens querem
celular bom roupa tudo então quer dizer
não importa o técnico ser pobre ou isto
é de uma religião de outra todo mundo
aspira as mesmas coisas então o que nos
separa geralmente são as classes porque
nós não convivemos os mesmos ambientes
entanto não têm oportunidade de conhecer
o outro mas tudo igual então isso é algo
que tem que ser quebrado nós temos que
aprender a se comunicar e conviver com o
outro e desconstruir a unanimidade de
pensamento só iremos construir a unidade
de pensamento com debates com convivendo
com outros diferença
e para encerrar eu enxergo nelson
rodrigues dizendo todo o nome toda
unanimidade é burra quem pensa
comunidade não precisa pensar obrigado